i want to go to maria villarreal now
who's in port natchez texas not far from
here
where she wrote out the storm and where
many others did as well maria good
morning to you what are conditions like
where you are
hey you know tony at one point this area
the beaumont area was expected to take a
direct hit from laura but as the storm
shifted to the east we did see
some heavy rain overnight and also some
very strong
winds but you know after hurricane
harvey hit here about three years ago
and then they had tropical storm imelda
with all of that flooding last year
a lot of people were not willing to take
another chance
i'm thankful for this place i mean i
really am
jake johnson left port arthur heading to
houston where he slept in his cousin's
truck before arriving at the forge for
families
a local non-profit community center now
serving as a shelter
thousands of people evacuated from this
area because they were worried about an
excessive amount of rain
of flooding and potential for storm
surge but what we have seen right now
is an absolute wind storm
although the storm didn't hit this area
as hard as predicted
dana thomas executive director for forge
for families
says they still had to add another layer
of planning
with coronavirus concerns in play
families that started coming this time
had to face not only the displacement
issue but the covet issue so
having to have your temperature checked
to even be able to enter the facility
was a new
caveat coveted space restrictions means
shelters filled up quickly
and some evacuees were turned away from
those centers
even as hotels ran out of available
rooms
henry vandepute of the houston red cross
says people in need
will not be left without a place to go
if we reach capacity
we're going to be with that client until
they have somewhere else to go okay so
we're not going to let that be a
a deterrent to finding somewhere safe to
be
and that's our commitment
people here like to tell me they don't
they don't want to say they dodged a
bullet instead they want to say they
were
over prepared right now there is a storm
surge warning that's still in effect for
jefferson county and some of the
surrounding areas right now there's
about 70 thousand people at least
without power
just in this area alone and it could
take days if not a full week
before those lines are repaired tony
yeah all right maria thank you very much
and gayle and anthony as i toss it back
to you
i want to keep in mind that it is always
a good idea to be over prepared so we
hope
most people were able to get out and get
to safety here a concern for officials
is
many people may have thought hey i made
it through hurricane rita in 2005
i'm sure i'll be fine this time as
daylight continues to grow here
the worry is maybe not there's no
guarantee so we'll have more
for you as we learn more but in the
meantime sending it back to you guys in
new york
yeah it's good to see the daylight
coming up tony your story was very
frightening at least you can see now
what you're dealing with there
thank you very much